21 years ago when I'm 23 years old I'm  at a sales office I just became a  financial advisor and I know this in the  month of October everybody was working  hard November everything is good the  moment Thanksgiving came I noticed  people are coming to the office later  leaving early or taking off Friday you  know what that meant to me this is my  chance to recreate myself so no one  recognizes me beginning January 1st so  if that's you and you want that to  happen to you as well this is Cyber  Monday and Black Friday sale and we got  many different courses and many  different bundles over ten thousand  dollars in savings but it's only for  Black Friday Cyber Monday if you want  2023 to be the beginning of the greatest  years of your life click on the link  above or below go get one of these  bundles for yourself and start  recreating yourself so no one recognizes  you the beginning of 2023